[Musica]
no no non puoi portarlo poiché tar devi
premere solo un dente non tutti ma
berlino non puoi mordere sul conca treno
il coccodrillo che devi premere solo un
dente così vedi non puoi morderlo così
prova ma berlino no non puoi mangiare il
coccodrillo
vabbè lascia perdere
che cosa è stato
[Musica]
o no berlino bravissimo ti sei nascosto
qua mai fatto benissimo a nasconderti
già mi sa che si toccherà a fare un
altro nascondino con dei nuovi pezzi che
sono entrati in casa mi stai ascoltando
ma tu non hai mai paura
ciao ragazzi nuovo episodio nascondino
avete visto ma sono entrati dei nuovi
passi in casa come in ogni episodio alla
fine questa volta penso che sia ciò che
mi è sembrato di intravedere ha preso
che ci sia anche qualcun altro mi è
sembrato di sentire degli altri passi
voi come sempre lasciate un bel mi piace
entro 5 secondi 521 via che cosa stai
mangiando berlino il solito ladro fare
silenzio vuole per portomaggiore questo
comunque ci saranno quattro round è se
vinco per due round ho vinto ma se perdo
per più di due round avrò perso la
challenge e avrà vinto chat mettetevi
comodi prendete i pop corn e e siete
pronti ad avere paura
mettiamo subito la sala
[Musica]
ho deciso di tenere questo come
nascondiglio sotto alla mia scrivania
perché penso che se esco di qua mi
troveranno subito
fate il tifo per me mi sono dimenticata
di dirvi se non mi seguite ancora su
instagram andate a seguirmi il nome
alita stories securitate seguirmi anche
sui tic toc il nome sempre anita stories
e sono feti visto lo scorso pd in cui
giochiamo a nascondino in un bosco
stregato andate a vederlo dopo questo
video
[Musica]
berlino grazie per avermi svegliato
credo che questi bacini berlino o no
abbiamo già perso il primo turno avete
visto che brutta quella bambola non è
chucky ma si chiama tiffany ed è la
moglie di charlie se non lo sa come
fanno due bambole a sposarsi ma io non
farla arrabbiare è venuto l'idea per
questo secondo round come nascondiglio
uscirò fuori sarà più difficile per loro
trovare con un palo e ora che ci penso
siamo due contro uno nascondiamoci sotto
a quell'albero vendome penso che mi
troveranno che stai facendo rincorrendo
le lucertole rimarrò qua nascosta tanto
non penso che riusciranno a trovarmi
capiamo sembran credo poco avete visto
giochi tiffany erano sopra l'albero
sassari che la soprano le gambe così
corte ok
torniamo dentro casa velocemente se non
fatta ho vinto il secondo turno di o
chiusi la fuori stavano cercando di
entrare ma ho chiuso la porta
secondo turno punto per me
passiamo ora al terzo turno
[Musica]
ok ragazzi per il terzo turno ha deciso
di nascondermi dentro questa scatola
vi ricordate anche i video abbiamo visto
per la prima volta questo scatola
vediamo chi se lo ricorda scrivetelo nei
commenti tre ro qua dentro e potrò
spiare la situazione da qui e non sa
dove posizionarla però questo angolino
forse no ma la metto davanti alla porta
così blocco l'entrata e netta che metti
fani potranno entrare in casa ho fatto
la statale ragazzi sono qua mi vedete
non c'era nessuno che sono qua dentro
o no
chi sei tra ragazzi avete visto ciò che
ha aperto la porta ed è entrato spero
solo che non gli venga in mente di
controllare dentro a questo cartone non
c'è per nessuno aiuto sono sirtaki che
tiffany sono pesa la maniglia della
porta magari provo a spostarmi un po
lontano da qua
ok ragazzi non sono riuscite a spostarmi
molto nel camminare molto umana sono
riuscite a girare la scatola dall'altra
parte così almeno non ho la loro faccia
di fronte e magari non mi trovano spero
provo a infilargli un dito nell'occhio
miste che fratello modo forse funzionato
lo davvero spaventato e se n'è andato
[Musica]
o no perso il terzo turno questo è il
quarto e ultimo round se perdo questo
round avrò perso per sempre
se vinco questo round avrò vinto la
challenge sta portando via po stare
molto più attenti a scegliere il posto
in cui nasconderci dove potremo
nasconderci questa volta a merinos off e
spero che non abbiano preso merlino
forse meglio uscire fuori a cercarlo e
nasconderci fuori all'aperto
mi è venuta in mente un'idea per
sconfiggerli giochi tiffany sono lassù
vediamo cosa stanno facendo mia che
schifo
andiamo
ma tira cast e sono riuscito a uscire
sana e salva dalla casa ma non è ancora
detta l'ultima parola perché non
riusciranno a trovarmi quei ragazzi ecco
il mio piano non appena si avvicineranno
ciò che ti fan
gli risposero con questa pompa ad acqua
sperando che abbiano molta paura
dell'acqua o qualcosa del genere
insomma che si allontanino spero che
funziona
eccoli la giustizia non vicinanze
avvicinatevi pure non ho paura di sette
l'acqua che vi aspetta capi questa
cerchi sono riuscita a far cadere cia
chimati pane ancora lì dov'è
[Musica]
i tifoni scomparsa
ora manca giochi però che sarà la secolo
sì ce lo abbiamo fatto abbiamo vinto la
challenge a nascondino con tracciati e
tiffany lasciate un bel mi piace se
volete altri nascondini di paura e ora
vi lascio pa 4 castellini su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione
[Musica]